OK, so now let's go from talking about police
to talking about destruction of property.
There are reasonable people who have centered
in on what seems to be a dividing line as
we see unrest and protests and physical violence
and property damage around the country.
When we talk about property damage, there
is often a debate as to whether it counts
as violence in the sense of when people say
I am against violence.
So most people agree attacking random bystanders
who aren't being violent is unacceptable violence,
attacking random police who aren't doing anything
wrong.
That is violence in an in any sense of the
word.
Most people agree blocking traffic is not
violence.
Now, you.
Before or against blocking traffic as a protest
tactic.
But most people would not say blocking traffic
is violence up.
You could maybe say, well, if you prevent
people from getting to work and then they
lose their jobs, blocking traffic becomes
kind of like economic violence.
But in the kind of violence we're talking
about, blocking traffic.
Most people agree is is not violence.
What about property damage?
So, first of all, we have to call out the
right wing hypocrites on this issue.
The concern trolls who a month ago were saying
sacrifice grandma to corona virus in order
to open the economy, who are now saying the
worst thing you can do is break the windows
of a big box store.
They are hypocrites.
I'm not interested in those hypocritical,
concerned trolls.
I want to deal with the real people, with
the sensible people who in a real way want
to talk about this.
There are folks who believe that, for example,
destroying government property when no one
gets physically hurt is OK.
But for example, destroying a private business
is not OK.
That depends on who you're targeting.
You could be targeting a business with bad
practices or you could be targeting a government
that is a bad actor or whatever.
You could find, you know, a logging company
and say we are going to destroy or disable
their bulldozers so that they cannot take
down these trees.
Saying what determines whether destruction
of property is violence is merely whether
you're doing it to a government property or
to private property.
I don't think that's really the dividing line.
What this comes down to is what do we mean
by violence?
Violence defined as behavior involving physical
force to hurt, damage or kill someone or something
damaging property even sort of fits.
If you want to take a legal perspective, certainly
the unlawful exercise of force or the exhibition
of such force would encompass the destruction
of property.
Now, others would say the real crux of human
violence versus physical violence against
people rather than objects is where we should
be focusing.
If you are talking about breaking a window,
that's not really what a lot of people believe
is violence.
So here's the bottom line.
If you want to make this a semantic argument,
if you want to make this about definitions,
you can define violence in a way that does
or doesn't include property crime.
It won't really get to the underlying issue.
And the underlying issue is whether sometimes
violence is justified.
So even if we agree on whether property crime
is or is not violence, that doesn't answer
the question of whether property crime, destruction
of property is a valid form of protest.
Who gets to decide what's in the protesting
playbook?
If you leave the protesting playbook only
to the elites and those in positions of power,
it will be restricted to only writing letters,
you know, chanting and holding signs.
Right.
The point is, if you let those already in
power define what is OK in terms of protesting,
certainly nothing will ever change.
Now, is there any guarantee that destroying
property is going to achieve change?
There's not.
We do know that destruction of property has
been a part of protesting for a really long
time.
You look at the Boston Tea Party destroyed
property to fight back against the capitalist
monopoly and political rights that were being
claimed by British colonists.
You look at slave uprisings in the United
States, which included destruction of property.
You look at the plowshares aid.
A group of eight Christians, including priests
and nuns who took hammers to the nose cones
of some nuclear warheads, poured their blood
on the facility's papers and a call for peace.
So the legality part of it is clear this stuff
is illegal to do.
But I think we can all every single one of
us imagine a situation where we do the moderate
methods and they bring no change.
They don't get attention.
And then you say, well, we don't want to do
violence to people, but we're going to start
destroying some property destruction of property.
In my mind is clearly violence of a kind,
but in certain situations, it might be the
only thing people have left short of starting
to actually do violence to individuals.
Now, which situations count?
I don't know.
What about the consequences?
Well, there are consequences.
You're not going to get around that.
Will property damage get you what you want?
Often it will not.
Property damage may, in fact, do the opposite.
It may turn public opinion against you.
But whether property damage that's not hurting
anyone physically is a valid form of protest.
That's a question that goes back at least
hundreds of years.
And anybody pretending that there is one single
solitary answer that applies to every situation
is just wrong.
History tells us that's not the case.
I want to hear from you about this.
We're going to continue covering it on The
David Pakman Show Instagram.
At The David Pakman Show, we will take a break
and be back with much David Pakman show at
David Pakman Dot.com.